what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday november the 22nd
the joint is brought to you by on it
listen to me today is the
black friday
monday virtual sale at on it what does
that mean to you
that means that you they're dropping
their [__] prices they're giving [__]
away new mood on it black label
alpha brain black label shroom tech
immune shroom tech sport
club bats everything is going to be on
sale i advise you to go to honor.com
right now
don't miss this [__] sale it starts
today 60 percent off use code joey
they're to send you something extra a
little gift
if you use code joey go to honor.com
right now
right now you're going to start the
[__] year off
like i told you we're thinking of 22
right now we're not even [__] 21 is
done and over after thursday people
going to be talking about christmas
gifts and how they can't get [__] gi
joes for their kids because they're
stuck in bangkok [__] it audit.com
code joey the joint is also brought to
you by
blue chew listen thanksgiving is here
and i know you want stuff more than
turkey this year when you're old ladies
in the kitchen and she asks you to baste
her little [__] giblets
you want to be ready [__] and
that's where blue chew comes in
taran [__] up for years
you're like joey what is blue chew i do
not have erectile dysfunction i don't
give a [__]
everybody needs confidence
everybody needs a little help you're
like joey what's blue chew it's an
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and sialis
at a fraction of the cost you could take
it anytime
day and night the process is simple you
sign up at bluetooth.com
you talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
the best part is it's all online
the doctor's office no pharmacy no
judgment it ships right to your door in
a discreet package not even your mailman
knows
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
usa usa there you go
you did your [__]
thing for the week all right and blue
chew
is way cheaper than a pharmacy so if you
can benefit from extra confidence when
it's time to perform blue chew can help
and they got the same special deal for
you i've had for the last year why you
haven't jumped on it i don't know you
could see that your girlfriend's not
[__] happy now a good stabbing
doesn't solve the world's problems but
it makes mama happy try blue true for
free with promo code joey j-o-e-y just
pay the fin to get in five dollar
shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month free and as always
i want to thank bluechu for sponsoring
the joint they're great they taste good
and they work fast guys i love blue chew
it's a great product and it and it works
that's the most important thing and
while you're taking care of your dick
i'm gonna take care even more so you
look good
me undies ho ho ho [__] it's
jolly old uncle joey here with something
in this [__] stockton for you my sack
is full of the most comfortable
underwear around they call me undies
listen i've worked with me on these for
close to nine [__] years
i wear me on these i have me undies on i
love me undies if you look at my
underdraw underwear draw there's no
[__] white cotton white with skid
marks
i got me undies head to toe with the new
holiday sweater prints me undies is
turning up the comfort this season all
me on these products are made with soft
breathable stretchy fabrics
it's called more doll or nor doll i'm
not sure but don't be stupid me undies
isn't just underwears
joey i want to buy undies for grandma
they got everything they got loungewear
sleepwear matching pajama sets plush
robes slippers
and more whatever you decide
everyone will be rolling into the new
year comfier than last year
available in sizes extra small through
forex for your chubby uncle joey me
undies has a little something for
everybody on the list and if you're
shopping for something for joey i'm
gonna
kind of i'm a 2x kind of guy all right
listen up me undies has an offer for
listeners a joint for any first timers
you get 15 off and free shipping right
to your door i'm going to talk to you
about something guys
listen you're not going to get a lot of
gifts that you want this year it's going
to be rough out there i'm giving you a
nice selection with me undies you could
do all your christmas shopping one-stop
shopping who doesn't need nice colorful
underwear i got underwear on that have
little pop flowers on them right now are
you [__] kidding me me and these will
take care of you like i said for the
first time buyers fifteen percent off
and free shipping to your door your days
of fighting for your life in the mall
parking lot of [__] over i'm giving
you 15 off your first order free
shipping and 100 money back guarantee
but it starts with you going to
meundies.com
joey that's meundies.com
joey let's get this [__] party
started
uncle joey's here
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here with the joint it's
monday thanksgiving week that's it
four more days by friday morning when
you wake up you're gonna hear [__]
jingle bells and [__] like that and it's
still
i think it's still november the
following week like half the week but by
[__] the ninth
once you hear john lennon it's over you
might as well get the presents and
there's no [__] presents the supply
chain is [__] closed i had to go to
philadelphia for [__] uh
close to this [__] town me and my
wife the other day like an hour drive to
get pokemon [__] cards and when we
walked in nobody even knew they were
there we're like when we got the pokemon
cards you know some people [__]
swarmed us they came from everywhere we
want pokemon cajon because they hide
those [__] but it was a great
weekend i had a
a [__] great weekend listen man
i used to have these high [__]
grandioso weekends like a flight
a big dinner on thursday
you know [__] around with dean or
kate on friday and then this huge show a
plane there was so much activity
on the weekends for me and now it's like
there's two activities like three
[__] activities
i hang out i drive them to whatever the
[__] they gotta do we had a little bash
friday night
this neighborhood is like very uh friday
nights it's very
it's the same people do the same thing
and thank god they do listen i lived in
l.a
i don't know how many years i knew 20
[__] millionaires and they never
opened up their home
and here the people are not millionaires
they're just regular working blue collar
[__] people and it's like
every friday they invite us over they
have pizzas
they cook a little something we sit we
[__] the kids have a basement they
run around and
it's
a [__] different world you know and
it's just nice you know saturday night i
did not watch the [__] ufc thank god
i wasn't uh
sometimes when you watch the ufc you're
like this is great but sometimes you're
like
it's saturday night
i should be out lighting my pubic hands
on fire or some [__] you know what i'm
saying like something should be [__]
happening here
but uh
yeah like this week i was i was [__]
ecstatic
i didn't make it to my high school thing
on thursday night out of work that was a
shame i called a few people and
apologized my high school teacher went
which was cool as [__] you know
so i called him and we talked a little
while mr barone and uh
i didn't make it thursday night but
saturday i wasn't doing [__] saturday i
took mercy to kick by i did what i had
to do around the house i had to
clean some [__] up the [__] leaves
jesus christ listen man i've never i
haven't touched leaves
since i was a [__] kid guys
i'm sore right now it's not from jumping
rope it's not from hitting a bag
it's not from lifting weights it's not
from walking
my [__] shoulders and my back hurts
from [__] raking [__] leaps i had
the gun out
the raker i have never raked leave i
haven't regulars before i haven't done
physical [__] labor
let's just let's just settle back on
that i haven't done physical [__]
labor in a long goddamn time and i look
forward to it it's not like you know i
mean i'm a little scared with the knee
i'm not picking up [__] ballots or
breaks and [__] like that
but physical labor of me just have been
not enemies but i just haven't been
around it you know for years when i
worked i remember being in snowmass
village and even though this is the
creepy thing about me like even though i
was a thief and i was rob and i was
dropping drug dealers and
snowman's village i was very focused on
my life like i always wanted to get
ahead a little bit
on the legit side you know i'm saying
like you always want to at least try you
don't want to be a [__]
donkey and just give your life away to
[__] being a thief i at least tried i
took classes but one of the things i did
i never talked about a pieceworked
painting
that is a [__] nightmare
they wouldn't even pay me like an hourly
rate like they would take a room like
this and say hmm
65 bucks
this is what you get you have to you get
65 bucks for this [__] room to paint
it that's the trim
that's taping that's the windows that's
the whole thing so you have to look at
it and go okay how do i make money on
this
65 [__] dollars i'm gonna try to make
20 an hour so i'm going gonna try to get
this job done in three [__] hours you
try to become an estimator in your head
like you know like a [__] labor guy
so you're like i gotta get this done in
three hours how am i gonna attack this
i'm gonna [__] tape the moldings i'm
gonna tape the door i'm gonna tape all
the [__] uh handles and [__] i'm
gonna do it thoroughly and just hit it
and you know once you're painting and
you hit the [__] once you hit the
corners and [__] the other thing is all
open paint with a brush you just smack
right through it so i would look at
something go i need to get this done in
three [__] hours
for me to make a [__] profit you know
what i'm saying so i would jump in it i
did all that [__] i used to [__]
shovel snow for a living do you know
what that's like
without a [__] plow and listen i
signed up for it when i was i took a bus
one day to the supermarket and i had
like
a lot there's a lot of seasonal work in
aspen and snow mass and i saw a sign
snow shovel is 12 50 what are you
[__] kidding me cash every [__]
thursday or you get paid daily
that's i love getting paid daily i love
it that [__] about waiting two weeks for
your money go [__] yourself i work today
i want to get paid today but the way
life is you gotta wait two [__] weeks
and
so i don't even know what i was talking
about ah who the [__]
i was the guy's name was joe coffee good
[__] white dude good [__] white
dude when your name is coffee
you're all right a good [__] dude and
i lived in cresskill d12
he lived in cresskill c12
that's a dog you know i never bust my
ass i would walk over a building knocked
on his door he'd give me two shovels and
an icebreaker and a bag of [__] icy
whatever the [__] that is to break up
the ice
and i just break up ice like they would
come all with the plows and [__] and i
would have to do all the sidewalks you
know like to have those gutters that
drip and [__] you got to break up the
[__] ice
and he would pay me [__] daily and i
love i love all that [__] i've never
been a lazy person i and i used to work
six [__] seven hours shoveling snow i
get out there at [__] eight in the
morning
break that [__] up take a little smoke
break a little [__] reefer break i
love work
that
listen there's a couple different type
of jobs there's like the jobs of the
serious
there's the jobs that you might go
somewhere in and then there's the jobs
that you could do for 30 [__] years
and nobody would even give a frenchman's
[__] about you
you ever have those jobs like nobody you
know like a landscape nobody gives a
[__] about you you don't move up as a
landscaper you know unless they hire a
mexican dude and then you're on top of
him because you speak english there's
you know i'm saying like you never move
up as a [__]
laborer you know as a mason i worked as
a [__] mason outdoors i like outdoor
work but i have not done it
in such a [__] long time i mean i
rate for like
two hours on friday and two hours on
saturday because the guys are coming
today if you drive on my street there's
piles of [__] leaves well i'm not
putting bricks in those [__] piles
and the other night i was driving right
i was driving back and i saw a big pile
of leaves i'm like maybe i'll go through
it right before i went like
maybe they got some crazy kids like i
was in the neighborhood when i was a kid
i put bricks in those [__]
i put bricks in those [__] uh
leaf piles
we did
it just [__] perfectly
charles court was a circle it was uh
not really uh
like uh whatever the [__] you have at
the end of this yeah it's not a
cul-de-sac it was actually a circle
there was an island in the middle with
three houses and you would have to go
around it it was the perfect block to
[__] lay
uh leaves on a [__] you know to
[__] torture people after about 8 30
the street would die down there wouldn't
be that many people on the street it
would just be people driving that worked
in the city
coming in so we would take a 12-inch
block
the [__] big blocks and built like a
pink floyd mini wall like for midgets it
was just a little wall for me just to
take a hop over we wouldn't put no
cement or not like that we just put like
two layers of bricks and then we put
pile the [__]
the leaves on top so what we would do is
we leave one thing of leaves
we'd have like two piles of leaves so
they could hit both of them and go oh
this is fun
right we can hit these [__] leaves
now they're coming up to the third one
that's where the brick wall is at
ba boom once they hit that [__]
they would get out we'd be in somebody's
backyard behind bushes
howling the guy looks around [__] you he
would always like whoever it was was
always a guy like an older guy that
would hit him there wouldn't be women
out at that time and then what we would
do is
we would put like more piles
and he would go around them
and then the third so there would be
basically nine piles and three stacks of
bricks with two openers that
there's no brick so once you pass by
them there's no bricks on that one
there's no bricks in that one i'll hit
this one boom and that's when your
[__] car hits the [__] wall i you
know i did all that craziness i can't do
it now i mean i'm i'm 58 years old i
would love to [__] do it now
but i can't that's just the way life is
but anyway we're talking about physical
work
i don't know
i don't know i don't know i was thinking
about maybe loading trucks or something
i don't know listen you could do all the
lifting you want
when it comes to work those are complete
different muscles
trust me i'm telling you i don't care
what job you do i don't care if you do 2
000 [__] pull-ups a day if you get a
job sweeping the next day you're going
to go jesus [__] christ
i can't even [__] move i gotta do
[__] like
little by little like i can't even dive
into something like the leaves the other
day i can't dive into that for eight
hours i gotta break into that [__]
slowly what are we doing here talking
about [__] leaves who gives a [__]
about leaves it's fall they're supposed
to be [__] leaps
this last week i was waiting i love
movies
i i've always
i don't know if you guys know the
relationship i have with [__] movies
i love
them you know
you look at your life and you go wow why
how did i use movies
i think i used movies as a form of
therapy when i was a kid you know like i
just
when i wanted to check out and that went
was true even when i was a young man 21
i love matinees
i loved waking up in the morning
knowing that there was a double feature
somewhere and
like rick ramos you know
i don't know if you guys remember rick
ramos he's a dear friend of mine
comedian from the comedy store him and i
did weight watchers together we were
weight watcher partners
we've known each other for over 20 years
when it comes to movies he was a [__]
i mean he knew everything
it was
it would make me feel bad when i spoke
because i considered myself
a movie buff until i talked to him and
he would just shoot me [__] down
at every you know
he was just that knowledgeable about
movies he he was a movie bus buff plus
too
if you're into [__] movies you should
be listening to rick ramos and fi
following rick ramos i mean
i follow him lightly now like i see what
movies he does and i go jesus christ
that dude pulls up two good [__]
movies every week and if you listen to
his podcast
he really explains him like he explains
him he knows who the dps were he knows
who the [__] uh
he knows who who handled the cameras he
knew the stuntman i mean this guy
would say [__] to me
that would [__] the only movie he
don't know about is rust you know nobody
knows much about [__] rust
everybody's sitting there waiting when
they're gonna press charges on alec
baldwin that [__] i like that even
trump [__] threw up
till this day i love trump for what he
did to alec baldwin he said arrest him
he's got mental problems and [__] i
guarantee alec ball was like i should
have never done that saturday night live
thing and he kept doing it it came back
to haunt them trump is calling all his
buddies doj everybody [__] lock that
[__] up the rust shooter but i
was talking about movies you know and i
was really
we took a [__] hit
with the pandemic and i tell you who
took the biggest hits was [__] movie
theaters and i had no idea guys i had no
[__] idea
and
i'm not a big fan of the big movie
chains i can't stand those [__]
the amc's and all those especially after
what i went through
with them with the [__] screening
like
they just shut me down from every
[__] direction they weren't even nice
to me they weren't even nice to me but
the whole movie theater experience
bothers the [__] out of me for this
reason and i love movies
this is like a catch-22
you go to a movie you go to entertain
yourself you know you go you go to break
away from life's [__] bullshits you
know
you get into the movie theater okay
whatever they what they charge for a
movie eight to 12 bucks sometimes 15 i
don't know it is what it is you know i'm
saying
inflation life has changed you know i
used to pay two bucks for movies that's
a that's a long [__] time ago uncle
joey you know i'm saying get your life
together it's a long [__] time ago so
you know you go to the movies you pay
your 15 you don't give a [__]
you walk up to the thing you know and
you
you know they want ten dollars for a
soda and a [__] popcorn that tastes
like ass that amc popcorn is so [__]
bad
that's the worst [__] you could [__]
eat in the world make popcorn at your
house make real popcorn at your house
see how it [__] smells and then go to
amc and smell that chemical induced
[__] coma of chemicals they put in
there look at the [__] butter they
give you it's like a little [__]
milky but that ain't butter that's a
butter supplement to some [__] they put
in there like a butt
and then that you know the whole time
like i i'm not cheap and i understand
that
if you came to me right now and said
joey i want to sponsor your podcast i've
had friends come to me and i go listen
you want to respond to the pocket these
are the prices you know what i'm saying
they go some people go ouch and some
people go that's
that's the price that's just what it is
they don't try to [__] negotiate or
whatever when you go to the movie
theater you know you don't have a chance
to negotiate you don't want to be
[__]
johnny [__] jew you know what i'm
saying you don't want to [__] go up
there and tell the guy i'm not paying
eight dollars for a small popcorn i'm
gonna give you a 750 and start arguing
with the guy so you pay it
guys like me just pay it you pay the
[__] vague and you sit down
but after you sit down you open up the
razor nets they're [__] stale
you know the razor nuts are [__]
always stale that's my go-to of raisins
i love [__] raisin hats and you know
i don't eat the popcorn because it
tastes like ass you get the diet
coke or the coke [__] zero or you
make your own soda they have like the
machines that you press and [__] and
that's all great and dandy but when you
walk the [__] out of there
you're minus 30 35 for a movie
and you're like what the [__] did i do
that's why these people that complain
about these movies at home
like oh they're too much money think
about what you spend when you actually
go to the movies so what goes out to be
a good experience
turns out to be this experience like you
got [__] reamed
i know that's the way i feel when i go
to a [__] movie and i didn't i never
felt that way until about
way before mercy was born i was doing a
podcast and the lady made me watch two
movies i've never done a podcast like
that but i didn't care i needed to go
watch movies it was like a disney movie
and some other movie i picked a disney
movie i went down to the movie theater
in hollywood like i forget what the name
of it is [__] great movie theater you
pick your seats
before you go there i think they're
going out of business they file
something i don't know what happened
but you go down there you get your seat
and
they got [__] food beers
they got great they got a great [__]
chicken sausage
a apple chicken sausage with this
dressing on a [__] bun
delicious i took my wife no big deal now
i had like a 20 bill
i had like maybe two twenties and a ten
and i had a hundred dollar bill when i
walked down to the movie theater we
walked it was like three blocks away
i went inside ba ba boom we got whatever
the [__] sausage sandwich you know
uncle joey i [__]
went to the movie theater the movie
theater was enjoyable the movie was
great it was like a disney movie about
new orleans and [__]
i got home and when i went to empty my
pockets i saw the 100 bill was missing
so i went to the movie theaters with 150
[__] dollars
and i came back with like [__] 70
dollars i'm like i spent 80 dollars at
the movie theater now again
i'm not cheap but 80 dollars at the
[__] movie theater
for two [__] people that's a lot of
dough compared to where i came from two
movies for a dollar you sit down the
floor is sticky the chair don't go back
but nobody gives a [__] every once in a
while you hear somebody go out from a
mouse biting them on the foot no big
deal those are the movie theaters in
harlem that's what you want
went out to you know so
i got home that night and i'm like this
is [__] traffic 80 bucks
that not in boycott movies i'm not one
of those [__] [__] that's gonna
get mad you know it's just a now you
have to decide what movies you want to
go see is it in your [__] budget you
know like oh my god there's a movie in
my [__] budget how embarrassing is
that a movie used to be five bucks three
dollars for popcorn or soda and you
[__] but now they don't the what you
pay at the door
goes to the [__] movie people
whatever production house shot the movie
the profit that amc and all those other
movie theaters make
is on that [__] popcorn it's on that
[__]
sausage sandwich so
i get it
i understand how business works and i
don't you know i don't i don't want you
to listen
i make a profit mike makes a profit we
all try to make a profit
but when you're [__] denting me a lot
of people are not going to go back
that's why people watch these movies at
home so like i was getting to this week
i wanted to watch this king richard
movie
yes i'm a will smith fan i'm a [__]
tom cruise fan
i'm a fan of all those [__] people i
like to watch their movies brad pitt i
like their [__] movies i like their
acting whatever but this movie had
a special thing with me because it's
about a dad raising two girls
it's about the the williams sisters who
i really [__] like i mean i think
they're both savages serena and uh
and uh venus i have a little crush
on the one that's always on tv i get
them confused venus she's on [__]
every goddamn commercial before black
lives matter
so whatever racism whatever does not
apply to the serena sisters
those chicks always have 10 commercials
on tv watch a sporting event
watch a sporting event before [__]
halftime you'll see
[__] venus hitting the [__] ball
she's eating cheerios she's hanging out
with tony a [__] tiger so whatever
people always go oh
there's not enough black african
americans in commercials with you don't
hear serena saying that [__] because
they've been [__] giving her gold
since day one and it just seemed like a
nice story that i didn't know i thought
they were from florida
years ago i don't know if you guys
remember anthony edwards had a show on
animal planet
about pets and [__] and i had to do it
i got a call do you you know you're
really into your cat
do you want to go on anthony edwards
show so i went down and you know they
hired me for the [__] day
and something happened to one of the
cameras i mean it was a great shoot
tiffany haddish played a gargoyle or
some [__] like a a gargoyle that talked
like you know she played like a co-host
and anthony edwards was great he's the
guy from blackish for a lot of you
people we're not great friends i did a
show and he's a stand-up and he's also a
fan of stand-up comedy so i went over
and something happened to one of the
cameras they had a setup so it was just
him and me sitting there like two idiots
so we started talking you know about
different situations i always thought he
was from new york
but it turns out he was from l.a he was
from right there [__] compton
and he was telling me that he i don't
even know how the venus and serena came
up he was telling me that he remembers
being a kid
and going
walking past the courts
where her father would be coaching the
two little girls and like they had a you
know he just said this to me they had a
fight off like gang members people try
to rob them
but the dude just believed in his two
little girls and
i just thought that was a great [__]
story
so when they were doing a movie i was
like jesus christ will smith two little
girls
i watch it i was excited about it you
know i was like how am i gonna get to
the [__] movies
and then i saw it was coming on hbo max
and i was like jesus christ that's
[__] great you know so
i watched the movie i [__] enjoyed it
you know it was great movie you guys
know me i love all that [__] about dads
and stuff
i didn't think it was an academy award
winner but i thought it was a [__]
good movie you know i read this morning
or yesterday morning that
they got
booted just like the many saints in
newark they [__] released on hbo
warner brothers
did the same thing and you got the same
result
they ended up both making 5 million at
the box office so i didn't feel that bad
i didn't feel that bad about the
sopranos
this is a really good [__] movie king
richard so
but that's the thing it only made five
[__] million dollars but it did great
at home bunch of people watched at home
i watched it at home so i count as the
[__] minority mutt because i didn't
have time to go all the way to freehold
and watch a [__] movie but i enjoyed
the movie
um
it takes a lot of work to be a [__]
dad and either you're on
or you're off as a dad you know we can't
have them both
you're either on or off as a dad you
have a dad that
is 100 percent
[Music]
you or you have a dad that
you know
that's got to work man
dad's gotta
put money on the table a lot of you guys
are younger and
you have a new modern
house with a new modern outlook when i
was growing up
it was just
you know men went to [__] work
men worked went to work every day and
men worked hard
and women
were in charge of all the household
[__] things so as a child
you saw your dad on the weekends and at
night when he beat the [__] out of you
for the stupid [__] you did that day or
whatever i'm just making jokes here but
you know
i know a lot of people today that
have gone into therapy because of their
dads i have a friend who his father was
uh
a little bit on the uh whatever side so
his dad he had to go to therapy over it
and find out what it really was
you know a lot of people
did not
really appreciate the household they
have a friend a dear friend
that
you know after it was all said and done
years later we went out to eat one night
and he was telling me about his house
and i was like like
we were eating dinner it was a bunch of
friends
and after the dinner i had to pull them
aside and go listen i don't have parents
so for you to say that [__] about your
parents that
they didn't pay attention to your [__]
it's [__] [__] and with dear
friends and we almost got into a fight
we had to get pulled apart because he
felt that i was insulting him but i
wasn't i was just explaining to him that
you're actually going to therapy because
you didn't think
your dad did a good job with you i mean
i know your dad i grew up in your house
i went to your house [__]
you know 10 times a week your dad was up
but
in his world
he thought his dad worked a lot of hours
and [__] like that
that was the gayest thing i ever [__]
heard in my life but i understand
you know i understand some people this
is why
part of me
didn't really want to go on the road
when i moved here mercy's getting to an
a listen in l.a she was a [__]
eight-year-old up to eight years old she
was a [__] kid she's gonna be nine in
january and a big nine
like her mind is [__] big she hears
everything she knows a lot
she asks a lot of [__] questions
she's the type of kid that i could see
mercy
coming from like she did she came to me
two years ago and said listen
i need for you to stay home a little
more you know i need you at the house a
little more mom needs you at the house a
little more so i could see mercy being
one of those whiny [__] suckers
that comes to me when she gets older and
said you know cuz kids are like that you
know i went to penn state i did all
these great things but you were never
there to be my father you know and that
bothers you that does [__] bother you
and i know a lot of you feel that way
think about it a lot of you just feel
that way maybe you had an older brother
you feel your dad spent more time with
your older brother whatever
i've always i
you know guys for me
since i was 17 i couldn't wait to have a
[__] family i just couldn't wait i
just couldn't wait to be a dad i look at
mike i look at mike you know mike's a
dad he's got two kids i knew him before
he had kids
but it's just so crazy mike is a dad now
when i talk to mike
yeah we talk about music and his open
mics and [__] but we talk about being a
dad he knows what it is to be a dad and
he welcomes it
you know i have a i get a lot of slack
from people every once in a while when
people get mad at me they [__] attack
me
and they attack me at a low end they'll
say to me ah well look at you you
[__] ran on your daughter they say it
to me to [__] hurt me i'm a lot
smarter than that
that [__] doesn't bother me because i
did not run out on my daughter
i just tried to give us both a better
life and that's the only way i knew
how to do it but now i'm confronted
again
with
having a daughter and i'm stepping up to
the [__] pump
that's why i watched king richard i
wanted to see what he was doing
different if he noticed in king richard
john bernthal's in the movie
john bernthal plays the tennis coach in
florida that they go to that was steffi
graf's
tennis coach and [__] [__] great
movie
and
i spoke to burnt all about it like
that's why he had the mustache
in the soprano scene because he was
shooting this movie at the same time
there was he had to go from one set to
another
but the interesting thing about the
movie
that john told me that they got to talk
to
you know his father and john did a lot
of research on the father and he goes
you know the father was [__] crazy
he was crazy he raised him a crazy way
the way he pulled them out of the pro-am
and the summer leagues and all this [__]
but he did it all to make a statement
sometimes you have to make a statement
when you're on the rise something a lot
of people don't know is
this is why i was always a big fan of
peter grant
led zeppelin's manager because he did
what was best for the band i got into
the entertainment business and i've been
around [__] managers and agents and i
gotta tell you something
out of all the managers i met over the
years i've been doing this for 30 years
in the comedy game i don't know the
music game i know the comedy game
there's three
really good managers working today
three
really
good old-time managers working today i
don't even know how we got on this
conversation but
the rest of them are [__] shitheals
it's just like uh
they're not and the and when i look back
at these managers
the thing that they're lacking is
commitment
commitment is everything you know
commitment is everything
when i was jackie's father
i was just a father
i was going through the motions
i'm honest enough to say this
when mercy came along
i'm committed
my commitment isn't her
why because i know if i put a little bit
of effort into her
if you put
sixty percent effort into your kids
you're gonna get thirty percent effort
back
they're not gonna [__] take all your
you know i'm saying they look at you i
see it with kids now that are older than
mercy
when i go to games and stuff i see how
their parents talk to them and how they
react to their parents
you get 60 you get 30 effort back from
your [__] kids they can't put what
you told them together
so
fatherhood to me i had to study it
because this is what i wanted to do i
didn't just want to be a mediocre dad i
didn't want to be a
a 50 committed dad i wanted to be all in
but to be all in
i couldn't do all the other activities i
was doing let me tell you something guys
i'm coming towards the end of this taper
and i focused everything
on
marijuana for this taper to help me and
it's been great i've been sleeping with
the edibles
you know the weed calms me down at night
i only smoke one joint but i can tell
already in about
a year or two that i'm not going to be
able to [__] smoke because every time
i smoke dog
even with the freeze pipe my lungs
bother me later like it's but it's not
my lungs it's not the freeze pipe it's
my mind playing tricks on me
all right my mind likes to play tricks
on you because then it connects
what i'm feeling to covet
so it's just listen guys some people
smoke pot and they get paranoid right
some people smoke pot and they [__]
eat 22 [__] bananas
i smoke pot and [__] in my mind because
that's the level of reefer i'm at right
now i'm at the 411 i'm at the 40-year
mark you just don't get high and sit
there and eat doritos anymore now your
[__] addiction or whatever the [__]
you call it your reefer
changes things that you do on reefer i
don't get like i went out to dinner
saturday night my friends are like oh my
god i smoke pot and i [__]
i [__] uh
you know i got so paranoid i couldn't
cope i and i tell them all take cbd
whatever i'm not up to that part in my
pot smoking i'm too part of my pot
smoking career now that the reefer goofs
on me
like the reefer goofs on me i smoked the
[__] reefer and next thing you know i
got covered it's like i used to have
that joke because it's true
i used to eat edibles and forget i'd eat
them
and i'd always go i think i got diabetes
like that was my goat i got diabetes i
got diabetes i got diabetes i would go
to the doctor the next day and say i
think i had diabetes and he would talk
he would ask me to tell him why and i'd
tell him to go get the [__] out of my
office you don't have no [__]
diabetes but that's what the reefer does
to me now it makes me feel like i got
covered but my point is i can tell
already that i won't be smoking in like
two or three years because my mind won't
let me my mind will shut it's like when
i eat something i'm not supposed to eat
now my my my body's like that don't
taste good
it tastes like [__]
later on i go
[Music]
it didn't taste that [__] bad but i
just my body can't deal with it no more
that's all it is you outgrew it i can't
go get a [__] baconator now if i eat
a baconator i'd [__] die on the spot
like i've never eaten a baconator i
don't even know what a bacon head is my
friend said he had to stop on the way
home and get his wife a baconator so i
knew it was something [__] not good
it's like a double cheeseburger yes
oh my gosh
and the bacon like lee always eats bacon
on his hamburgers no more thank god
lee likes bacon on everything and he
would get mad at me how come you don't
put bacon on your hamburger
dog because they give you [__] third
world bacon they ain't even thought
every [__]
bacon
everything i've tried that they put
bacon on
has like [__] it tastes like you got the
cheap you don't use oscar maya cena cut
if you're gonna wrap [__] bacon with
something you got to use oscar maya
center cup that puerto rican bacon that
they use people use the steaks those
burgers i went to burger brothers one
day and i got a burger and it came with
bacon i don't eat
burgers or bacon but i forgot to tell
them to take it off i took the two
pieces of bacon off and threw them to
the side and after about half the
hamburger i looked at that bacon i go
let me just taste it it was [__] god
awful
god awful it tasted like the bacon they
gave jesus before they put him in the
[__]
in the tomb of death it was [__]
terrible
what were we talking about i don't even
[__] lie i didn't even put i put in
like one bet last week
that's so [__] weird how i gamble i
don't gamble like a lot of people that's
why when i start a sports betting
service i don't think i have a lot of
customers
i really don't the style of betting i do
is the style i bet and i do is [__]
for fun
it's 25 bucks
and it's for fun so i really gotta like
some a lot to [__] bet
so i don't like a lot of things i don't
bet baskets because it's a [__]
nightmare you get killed
so it's just football for right now
that's all i got i'm not gonna [__]
i don't bet unless i [__] have to
yesterday i think i put
no bets in
i didn't bet like you know it doesn't
mean i'm the type of guy i gotta really
really really like something
if i see something i don't like losing
i'm one of those [__] i don't
like paying the bookie i worked i worked
too hard to be given a [__] book
money every goddamn week so
that's just the way it is but no
the other thing i did this weekend that
was pretty interesting
and i didn't know
i hate making [__] plans
i really [__] do like i said earlier
i didn't go to my
high school reunion and i felt really
bad about it
but with my anxiety when i make [__]
plans
like as the date gets closer i get
[__] anxiety about the situation
so yesterday was really nice my brother
mike
whose wife died
called me a few weeks ago and he was
like hey man
i think i'm going to come up for my
birthday i'll keep you posted maybe we
go out to eat or something like that i
said sure i like mike a lot
out of all my friends i i've really uh
he's not even a friend he's a brother
mike ronnie
uh good guy
you know
my wife and daughter understand my love
for him
you know especially my daughter really
likes him i my daughter likes anybody
who helped me as a kid like she wants to
meet
all my friends that were around me as
kids you know so it's kind of nice so
she always
takes to mike so uh sadly
we didn't have [__] to do
i did some stuff in the daytime and then
uh
we were just sitting around we were
gonna go to a party saturday night
mercy had a party at one of those places
where you [__] jump on rubbers and
you know swing ropes you like [__]
tarzan jr
i like going through those things but
sometimes i don't you know but these
people that were gonna have it were
really [__] cool i like the kids i
like her
i like him we were supposed to go to
dinner with them last week but they had
we had to change plans nice [__]
people so
my wife goes you're gonna go at 5 30.
i'm like absolutely you know i'm gonna
go
say hello watch the kids eat some
[__] pizza everybody has pizza
so
we were sitting around i was cleaning up
in the office and my wife comes in and
she goes you have a visit
i'm like what i got a visit and when i
looked there was mike running
like what's up what are you doing here
goes i told you i was thinking of coming
up for my birthday i wasn't sure so i
didn't call you
but i'm in the mood so he his uh
ex-wife who his wife died by the way and
it's it's tragic
his ex his wife passed away last
september
but her family lives 20 minutes from me
so his father-in-law is in the hospital
so he wanted to come up before
thanksgiving they don't think he's got a
lot of time left
but i guess he went over there and he
had plans with them or whatever but
something went wrong so
he had nothing to do so he goes [__]
that i didn't want to call you i just
wanted to stop up and see the house
whatever
so it's kind of nice i mean i don't i
usually don't like i get mad at people
when they don't call and come over but i
didn't give a [__] when it comes to
mikey do whatever he wants you know and
he came in we [__] a little bit i go
what do you want to do you know and i
said listen i'll take you to el nido
you know uh just me and you we'll go get
a quick bite if you want after five it
opens we go at five
so we don't you know
we don't have reservations or whatever
and he said
he really wanted to go to a place up
north he goes i really want to go to
this place because me and my wife used
to go to this place
it was my wife's favorite place and his
he was telling me what they would do
they would go there for birthdays and
anniversaries and the whole [__] deal
and i was like you know man if that's
what you want to do
that's what we'll [__] do i'm not
doing anything you're my brother i know
he's struggling you know
so i said better yet let me make some
calls and see if i get
some other ones of our buddies to
[__] uh meet us
so my buddy stink came along with us and
mercy's godfather said i can meet you i
get out of work and he works right there
so this all went down at four [__]
30. i mean just how i like it no plans
no reservations
no tuxedos no [__]
we uh smoked a little bit
and i got my car and i drove him up to
monarchy new jersey a place called
segovia
and uh it was great we i barked on the
street
we smoked a little bit we went into
[__] segovia
it was they take no reservations there
which [__] drives me crazy mike when
you have no reservations that means i'm
gonna wait outside for an hour
so that was the biggest worry i had so i
shot up there even mike who's got a
heavy foot was like [__] joey jesus
christ 90 on the turnpike go [__] it
it's wide open who gives a [__]
we got up to a monarchy in like 40
minutes we got up there like a five
[__] 40
and as soon as i pulled up
there was a [__] line at the door i
go god damn it and it was cold out you
got to wait outside i mean it wasn't
like penguin weather
but still you're not comfortable you
know what i'm saying you're not getting
bit by mosquitoes but you're not [__]
comfortable
so as we're walking towards it i was
there in march with my brother george we
went there one day for lunch on a whim
he had to deliver some art there so i'll
follow you will deliver
and then i'll go eat with you
i got the paella last time
not bad
and we were sitting outside it was a
nice [__] damp but there was a door
in the side and i saw the waiters going
in and out of there
so i [__]
i uh
walk out with mike and as i'm walking i
go mike look at that [__] line god
damn it
[__] we're gonna be here for [__]
hour it's gonna take us an hour to get a
table
i said i gotta get to the sun the owner
has a son that bartends there and we're
kind of friendly his name is anthony
good [__] dude like i gotta get to
the sun i gotta so i saw the side door
and i go lord please let it be open
like all right [__] it so i run over
mike's like where you going i go jimmy
just check something
sure enough i open up the side door
that's to the bar
so i go mike come on come this way it's
like no no we're going to get caught
here mike shut up come on there's no
we're kids this ain't a [__] high
school principal come on so we walk into
the side door i say hello to the
bartender how are you doing good to see
you [__] back
and i cut right through
the side and there was a lady with a
[__] with a pad
and uh taking reservations
this line was all the way out the
[__] monarchy street i mean this
[__] line was long i cut through
everybody i saw i go she goes how many i
go four
diaz jose
and all of a sudden the owner popped up
and he goes hey good to see you i said
good to see you i gave him a hug
and i go you know we've been coming here
for [__] 40 years
40 [__] years so we all sat down we
got the table my buddies were there on
time and [__]
and here's what gets interesting
the first time i ate at that place
was may
of 82.
i was at my friend's house and his dad
and his mom went to eat there and they
brought it to go back
and i went upstairs to go to the
bathroom and i saw this to go back and i
thought it was chinese food i thought it
was steak on a stick
when i opened that [__] bag it was a
filet mignon that was two inches i was
beautiful charcoaled
i cut a little piece off and i ate it
i'm like holy [__] so i went downstairs
i asked my friend where'd your parents
go this [__] he told me this
restaurant segovia monarchy dog i didn't
give a [__] i was gonna rob a jewelry
store i was gonna rob somebody but i was
going to segovia the following weekend
and i don't know who the [__] we robbed
i think i robbed some [__] uh
refrigerators from this uh appliance
store i worked at in fairview new jersey
in richfield circle
i [__] got like 200 bucks it wasn't
even that expensive i didn't know what
the how much it cost to eat there and
whatnot
i took a girl there to eat holy [__]
this girl let me suck at titties we were
in high school after
we were in high school
she didn't let me have sex with her she
didn't go to north bergen she went to a
school like in union city i had kind of
like grown up with her i knew her and we
bumped into each other and we
reconnected and she had a car
i didn't have a [__] car at that
point so i said to her hey man you want
to go to
segovia i always had kind of a crush on
that nothing ever happened i think we
swapped spit after a basketball game in
the eighth grade one time
and i took her to segovia i don't even
know where this girl is anymore i don't
even know what her [__] name was i
just know she was cuban and she was hot
and we went out there
and you know when you're [__] 18 you
take somebody to a carpet joint
they lose their minds you're going to
get a hand job you're going to get a
little hit job and we're young you're
not going to get a piece of ass because
you're both 17 18
but you're going to get something you
know i didn't take her out there with
the with
any any
i didn't think i was even gonna get to
first base with this [__] girl look
at me 58 years old still talking like a
kid [__] first base i didn't think
i'd get the first base at this trick but
we went to segovia i got the [__]
surf and turf i tipped big i was acting
like [__] john gotti
i was like 18 i had my little polyester
shirt on and [__]
and after that we went somewhere and i
think i sucked the little titties and i
fingered and i was all hot and bothered
but then she went back with a boyfriend
the story of my life you know what i'm
saying they always go back with the
[__] boyfriend
but
now we just sat down and we had a great
[__] meal and we just talked about
how fast this had passed us like
high school was [__] so slow
you know when you get out of high school
and you
go to college
it's a little on the slow side but man
once you get to like 26 i don't know
what the [__] it is but time starts
flying
i don't know if it's kids i don't know
if it's
getting married i don't know what it is
but we all came to i mean every guy at
that table last night we've known each
other
i'm eight i'm 58 i've known
everyone on that table for 45 [__]
years
all of us grew up together we know
everything about each other i'm having
thanksgiving at one of their homes i
mean you know
this is uh
it's just amazing to sit there
with friends that you've known for 45
[__] years we talked about ex-wives
ex-girlfriends
it wasn't really a remember one type
night
it was just
we're just talking about our lives
you know who's eligible for retiring
you know
who's just got surgery who just got
double hip replacement you know one of
my friends got double hit replacement
my other buddy lost his wife my other
buddy
it's just
guys
pay attention to your lives
pay attention to your life after that
dinner last night i couldn't wait to
jump on the mic here today
and tell you i think the most important
thing i've ever told you guys was what i
learned last night
i went to dinner with four guys we all
had problems growing up we all came from
different type homes you know some of us
two of those guys three of those guys at
the table last night came from blue
collar homes
one of them came from a little better of
a home but
you know man
we came to the conclusion last night
that
this is fast
the last time all four of us were
together at that restaurant
was february of 93
that was close to 28 [__] years ago
and i got to tell you something it went
fast
the last time i went to dinner with
those guys at that restaurant
i was basically getting into comedy
they were just giving me the blessing i
would have been doing comedy
for two years in colorado i was coming
back to new york to get my life together
and uh
i ended up
you know doing comedy for nine months
and coming back that was to kick off
dinner
when i went to dinner with like eight of
them those four guys were there
and we ended up getting thrown out of
there we got so [__] up
we must have had 20 pictures of uh
sangria
we had a deal not to do blow before the
food came we didn't listen we just went
[__] crazy and started doing blow and
the guy asked us to [__] leave i mean
we were dipping them all night
but we were so loud our table was so
loud
we were tipping them all night we were
getting louder and louder and louder and
louder and then the funniest thing the
guy came over and he goes guys you know
i love you i know you guys are great
customers you've been coming here for
[__] 10 years
you got to wrap it up people are
complaining people are looking over here
at the table
so we all get up i don't know there's
maybe 10 of us we all get up
and we're walking out and i got a buddy
who's at the time god rest his soul he's
not with us anymore
he was crazy i mean we were all [__]
crazy
and i was selling valium at the time i
was a valium salesman i had like 200
volumes on me that night i was giving
them away at the dinner table people
falling asleep it was [__] it was
just a wild night
and i'll never forget that as we're
walking out the way that comes out with
two [__]
pictures of sangria and he puts him on
our table because wait
where'd you guys go
and as we're leaving my buddy goes roger
holloway goes guys there's more [__]
sangria he yells [__] in the
restaurant again everybody looks at him
he goes where are you guys going and
we're like roger we got to go they
[__] asked us to leave you know we
didn't get thrown out like 86
we got asked to leave
you know nicely so we could come back it
was one of those they were that nice we
tipped heavy they didn't want our 86s
so roger went back and goes i'm not
[__] leaving without drinking those
things are 16 apiece and i'll never
forget he went back to the table took
the picture from the guy's hand didn't
even pour in the glass just started
tipping it back there's a it's 100
people in this dining area and 50 of
them were looking at roger as he's
drinking this [__] thing and he puts
it he goes ah
he lives out a little burp
and he looks around and he sees a table
with like you know four parents and like
four kids
like young girls and he walks over to
the table and he goes up to the head of
the house he puts a picture in front of
him he goes here you finish this knock
yourself out you bad [__] and he
goes
and he just turns around the whole
table's [__] looking around the whole
everybody's looking at us and that was
the last time
we were [__] in there so we were
talking about that last night when we
were sitting there we're like oh my god
the last time we were here
i hope they don't [__] remember and
sure enough mike opened up when the
owner came over in the sun and he's like
we were coming here since before you
were born the guy's like i'm 40 i'm
gonna be 40 next month and mike's like
we were coming here before you were
[__] born and he's like you're right
we've been coming here since may of 81
and we started giving the [__] guy an
ear beat
and they had a great time and then
mike's like i remember when there was a
bar on that side
and they're like how did you know there
was about the owner the owner's son was
like there wasn't a bar on that side
then the owner came over and he's like
tell them what you told me because there
was a bar
on the other side then nobody knew about
it was very tiny and when the owner
walked away he's like
he didn't know that i used to go into
that room and snort coke by myself and
[__] and one night he caught me he
didn't [__] remember
so thank god he didn't [__] remember
he just let us go they picked up around
the drinks we [__] ate
and uh
you're not gonna believe this we were
home by 9 30.
we were home by 9 30 and one of the guys
had to go to work at five o'clock in the
morning stinky and he kept telling me
that all night
guys this is all good for you but i
gotta go to work at five in the morning
i gotta be up at four in the [__]
morning this guy is a [__] uh
supervisor at ups done great with his
life
this guy has worked at ups
for 40 years
he doesn't remember i told him last
night go we went to that
job application together
we went to paramus they had like a
center where you went just for ups to
sign up for [__] uh
to sign up for work they interviewed
both of us he got the job i didn't it
was 11 to [__] two
ups 1981 he's been there for 40 years
he's like i'm eligible to retire they
want me to go
but i'm not going because i'm bored to
death i don't know what else to do with
myself he goes he has seven weeks of
vacation a year two of them with his
wife the other five he goes i don't even
take
i don't even take him i get paid yeah
because he goes what am i going to do
with my [__] time i have no friend i
go bro
that all changes this [__] i i would
love for all these guys to get retired
so we can hang on
maybe start a bowling league or
something like that get a bowling league
but this is it guys you got to welcome
this [__] like
the last couple of weeks i've i've been
thinking to myself maybe i feel bad
because it's a midlife crisis
you know maybe i feel bad maybe my
anxiety is up
you know but usually a midlife crisis
you dump your wife you [__] a 21 year
old and you get a corvette
i i looked last night i still got the
[__] subaru on a lot you know so
it's not a midlife crisis i don't know
what this is it's just
it's the final step
and the other night with dinner with
these guys
help me understand that i'm going into
the last phase i'm walking into the last
phase of life and i'm enjoying this
i'm uh welcoming it
i feel good
i'm gonna go to jiu jitsu today i'm
gonna start going to jiu jitsu a couple
times a week now i'm switching
you know guys i had a little moral
inventory last week and i got to switch
my [__] the last two or three weeks
i've been thinking about how i got to
switch my life around
my life has become very stagnant
and i'm very uh
i'm the type of guy that looks at that
[__] all the time when i become stagnant
i don't like it so i'm gonna switch some
stuff around
personal stuff i'm gonna switch some
fitness stuff like
i put too much [__]
uh
i put too much
into the gym i gotta start switching
around a little bit i got to start
balancing my gym
jiu jitsu a little more my health stuff
and i got to start you know i write with
erica i want to wish her a happy
birthday it was her birthday this last
weekend
you know i do uh i'm writing a book with
erica and that's a couple hours a week
we get together not to mention i gotta
outline on my own
because my memory is not that good so i
got outlined two three days beforehand
so i'm putting work into this but
something's still missing i need to fill
some [__] gaps and uh
the next couple weeks that's what i'll
be putting together i want to overall i
want to overhaul
the patreon a little bit and switch it
around
you know uh
i was thinking about how this week is
this week's i have on my patreon i
always have the album of the week and
it's just
it's not even a good [__] show it's
just me introducing an album to you guys
like i don't i don't get into it how i
would want to
because
i don't think you guys would enjoy like
if i got into a joey dear style it would
just be too [__] long the album of
the week so i try to keep it short but
the good thing about the arm of the week
for a guy like me is
that i get to play the album
like i listen to the album two or three
days
before i do the the album of the week
and i basically sit on my couch and
listen to both sides and relax
and just think
you know
i uh hit the bubbler and i'll come back
here be after 10 30. you know when i hit
the bubbler
and i'll come back here and i'll just
listen to it low
very low and then the next day when my
wife and my daughter's at school
i'll listen to the album you know
[__] loud and that's when i hear
things that i haven't heard in a long
time
when i put on the arm of the week this
week is the first hazy album uh the
blizzard of oz
this [__] album hit me hard this week
holy [__] and i let you know you hear it
all the time right i mean it was the
40th anniversary of diary or madman this
month the last month so they've been
playing the [__] out of it
and
they've been playing you know you hear
uh gravy training what's the name nice
crazy train
gravy tan i hit crazy train on the radio
hahaha you know suicide solution that
what is it
what is hard but risk is quick
suicide is low with limp
but you know you
you hear all those songs on the radio
and but when you like i told you
i didn't tell you guys i told the album
of the week people
when you
put an album on at the house and you
hear the way the songs come on the the
order of the songs like this week i
listened to two albums a lot i listened
to
uh the first ozzy and i also listened to
not the whole album i listened to
i would help uh
the first side
i went to hell
walk all over you touch too much that
[__]
[__] grayed out
that side i i i like how they did the
album selection on highway to hell the
five songs are just and then the other
song the other side is uh
went out of town looking for a woman
gonna give me good love and it ends up
with uh i'm the night stalker whatever
the night prowl i think i gotta look at
the [__] album maybe the night prowl
isn't the first that doesn't [__]
matter joey what matters is that i like
the wrote the way the songs are like on
the album it's on the aussie it's like
mr crowley i don't know you know suicide
the order i don't even think that's the
right order i must have still got some
of the thc from last night my [__]
coconut
but
i like it i like just sitting there
sometimes
and just listening to an arm and i'll
tell you what i don't hear the
instruments as much
it's not that you're listening to the
[__] album as much of the vocals you
know i'm listening to the bass because
rudy but then [__] uh sharon went in
there with
new musicians and we did all the [__]
bass licks she put them back in i don't
know if those are the original [__]
people it doesn't really matter but what
my point i'm trying to get to here is
that
it just takes you back
i mean it takes you back so [__] hard
for me i
it does and i'm not doing acid i'm not
doing anything guys look at my eyeballs
there's no acid in those eyeballs
there's no gorilla biscuits there's none
we're [__] we basically run on seven
joints a week
and a few edibles at night to help me
sleep they don't even do anything in no
more i can't wait
till the edibles finish and for you
edible people i got good news for you
i'm gonna do a little collaboration with
abx
the 200 milligrams are gonna be joey
diaz fire or something like that we
started talking last week so we're gonna
do a whole new [__] campaign with abx
put them on the map with their [__]
edibles listen man i love abx edibles i
love them i i love everything about the
only problem is i got to take a little
tolerance break right now i've been
running strong on those [__]
for four months i mean when i tell you i
am officially out of them
i went through a [__] case
on this withdrawal thing and they
they're great
if somebody's thinking of [__]
tapering off drugs or you're having a
hard time go to your local [__]
reefer store and get yourself a
uh abx 100 milligrams michael b my i
have
200 testimonials for the [__] abx
product
abx has been killing [__] you
know mcdonald's
served a million people well abx has
been killing [__] for four
years
it started with my man owen
[__] benjamin
i think i think the stars of death will
own benjamin i see i have both and i can
agree they are both
hard hard those edibles are hard thank
god the stars of death went out of
business that poor guy if you saw what
he looked like towards the end ass
[__] lee he couldn't even take it no
more he looked like a prune he was
wrinkled up he looked like sylvester
stallone and rocky when it rocky ii when
his eyes were all bundled up that guy
was giving himself tac beatings on a
regular [__] basis
but hey i love you [__]
it's monday the 22nd of the month uh
this is a holiday week
you know i should take this week off but
i didn't i know you guys are traveling i
know you guys need some entertaining
i know you guys want something in your
ear when you travel
usually i'm not the number one choice
but [__] it
i'm becoming the number one choice
little by little we're coming back
stronger than ever
we're making some changes and we're
gonna get stronger i feel a lot [__]
better guys this has been
a long year but i'm happy i pushed i'm
happy michael stayed on me and i pushed
through this and we're here every week
this might not be the best [__]
podcast in the world it might not be
what you want to listen to but we're
trying and we're here and we're
consistent
and i bring you nothing but love on a
monday morning for you to spread
all through the week
spread out some love try to make
somebody's day you know i had a great
time this weekend i think the best thing
about this weekend was that i made
somebody's day
i ended up making mike's day so
that means more to me than anything in
the world
i love you guys don't forget laughing
gas
oh you know what goes good with turkey
laughing guys [__]
before
after the turkey the next day for
football for college football and for
black friday don't forget
it is black friday so on it's going to
be that sun on it starts today
that's how [__] good we are with on
it we start [__] today on the
black friday monday virtual sale 60 off
of [__] everything or close to it
go over there knock yourself out take a
look
that's it and that's that i love you
[__] with all my heart i know
you're traveling this week we're here
patreon if you got questions we're here
if you got questions on twitter or
instagram we're here i love you
[__] don't forget to stop by
the ice cream shop
pick up some [__] laughing gas tell
them uncle joey sent you
and without further ado i love you
[__] with all my heart
have a great [__] monday have a great
[__] tuesday and i'll be back in here
tuesday with some [__] loving
stay black [__] have a great week
and a great day
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you guys
for having my back on a monday morning i
have no idea what i even talked about
today who gives a [__] but listen i give
a [__] about you the joint is brought to
you by blue chew thanksgiving is here
and i know you want to sling a little
helmet this weekend after turkey there's
nothing like eating a little turkey and
then giving mama stabbing whatever order
you decide
but you know what you're going to have a
full belly it's tough to [__] perform
sometimes when you have a full belly and
that's what blue chew comes in you're
like joey what's blue chew blue chew is
an online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis at a
fraction of the cost you could take it
any time day and night and the process
is simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com you talk to
them one of the licensed medical
providers
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days
the best part is it's all online
no doctor's office no pharmacy no
driving no judgment it ships right to
your door in a discreet package
and not even your mailman knows it
bluetooth tablets are made in the u.s of
a
and they're way cheaper than what you're
going to get from a pharmacy so if you
could perform
a little better and have a little extra
confidence when it's time to get down
blue chew can help you and they got a
special deal for you try blue chew for
free with promo code joey
again that's blue chew for free with
promo code joey just pay five dollar
shipping that's it that's bluetooth
promo code joey
and get your dick a little present and
get them all bundled up for [__]
thanksgiving and as always i want to
thank bluetooth for sponsoring the joint
the joint is also brought to you by on
it
today it starts
the black friday monday sale
60 off so i advise you to get the
[__] on it
jump on this [__] let's get this
party started
22 is coming right around the [__]
door you want to start off with a clear
brain
you want to start off at the gym you
want to start off doing things you
haven't been doing before walking you
know whatever you want to do but start
it up with on it why
they got great supplements and it'll
help your body from the shroom tech for
energy and endurance from the shroom
tech immune to new mood which you can
take at night it helps you [__] relax
and alpha brain the best nootropic out
there in the [__] market today
especially the black label alpha brain
pres and joey and they're going to send
you a little gift maybe a t-shirt or
sticker but go to honor.com
look at the fine line of supplements and
kettlebells i can't catch any deals on
the kettlebells but they're going to be
cheap today go to me undies pressing
code joey the joint is also brought to
you by
the best underwear in the business
me undies listen to me
the holidays are coming
nobody knows where to scramble there's
no gifts around whatever
you could get all your christmas gifts
on me undie
the most
comfortable [__] underwear loungewear
sleepwear matching pajama sets plush
robes or slippers you can find like i
said in the beginning i have me on these
on right now i've been working with them
for years
i got underwear still that i wear from
when i started working with them what
does that tell you
these are great underwear i have no
tighty whities left me on these is
turning up the comfort this holiday
season all meundie products are made
with soft breathable stretchy fabrics
joey i don't want to buy on these for
grandma i don't give a [__] don't be
stupid meundies is just underwear and
they have other things but what i'm
trying to tell you is
whether you decide everybody will be
rolling into a new year
more comfortable than before
everything at me on these is available
from extra small to 4x me on these is a
little something for everybody on your
list trust me don't bang your head on
the on the [__] wall this year going
to malls looking for [__] that don't
exist they're all on a ship with some
chinese guys smoking cigarettes just
looking at them and if you're shopping
for something special miyandi is going
to have it so listen up meundies has an
offer for listeners of the joint any
first-time buyers you get 15 off and
free shipping right to your door free
your days of fighting for your life in
the [__] mall
forget it it's over to get 15 off your
first order free shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
joey again that's meundies.com
joey i want to thank annette don't
forget
the black friday sale starts today i
want to thank bluechu they're here to
take care of your helmet and i want to
thank me and because they're here to
take care of your nutsack your helmet
the whole thing i love you [__]
with all my heart
thank you for listening i'll see you
guys wednesday tip top magoo
have a great halloween holiday season
stay black love you
[Music]
you